foreign
we are live on the world wide web I'm
Dave Rubin and we've got another Friday
Round Table
Extravaganza for you joining me today is
a trial lawyer and All-Star political
Gambler Robert Barnes as well as his
co-host of Viva Barnes law a sort of
part-time Canadian now Floridian
although I think he's in Canada right
now Viva Fry Guys welcome back to the
Reuben report
good morning glad to be here Viva I'm
going to start with you on the personal
note quickly you are known as a Canadian
with big hair you've moved to Florida
you are temporarily back in Canada are
you okay do you need me to get to santis
to send in the troops and get you back
here every time I send a hyper-critical
tweet of Justin Trudeau I half expect
someone to knock on the front door and
say yeah you might want to think about
deleting that I stepped back into the
Asylum and I and I almost mean that
literally it's a different culture it's
as though people in Canada still don't
know how the rest of the world are
living and they don't pay attention to
the politics they don't pay attention to
the legislative censorship and they just
don't seem to care and it's a very it's
a constant struggle how to make them
care how to sensitize them to it it
doesn't happen by being polite and you
know all cozy but you know being a
little too harsh on Twitter also gets
people to write the off so it's it's a
push and pull I'm trying to get people
to understand what's going on here it's
not normal and it should not be
normalized okay well just blink twice if
you need us to help you and Barnes it's
been a while since you've been on the
show you are in Las Vegas Nevada I was
in I was outside Reno Nevada a couple
weeks ago and on stage I said Nevada and
the crowd corrected me very clearly uh
how has life been for you since we last
saw you yeah they've been telling me
that forever I I don't know why they
want their steak to sound like a a lamb
you know I mean I do not get it you know
but it is what it is uh but a little bit
hot here uh but otherwise uh uh
otherwise okay intolerable
good good all right well you guys are
great legal Minds your show by the way
on Rumble has absolutely been blowing up
your live streams are getting great
numbers so I'm psyched to have you both
on and it's a good week for it because
we're gonna do a bunch of uh legal stuff
I think is the technical term uh we've
got some Elon versus Mark Zuckerberg on
this new Twitter clone threads that has
come out and there's a legal battle
around that right now of course one of
the big things that happened this week
there were a couple things Supreme Court
wise last week but then this week a
court order has now blocked the
administration's censorship of us the
people related to Big Tech and then they
found some cocaine in the white house
there was a noted guy who does cocaine
in the white house last week the
president's son but somehow they're
telling us they're not going to be able
to figure it out uh we're going to talk
about all that and more let me talk to
you guys about Mike box quick and then
we'll get to it you guys know that 60 of
U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called racked
upon which is banned in 160 countries
including China yet you find it in your
grocery aisle every day well there's a
better way and you know what it is it's
moink moo plus oink moink delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door you choose the
meat delivered in every box like Ribeyes
chicken breasts to pork chops to salmon
fillets and much more plus you can
cancel anytime there's nothing better
than cooking a little filet mignon on my
big green egg on a Friday night Shark
Tank host Kevin O'Leary called moink's
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
and they guarantee you'll say oink oink
I'm just so happy I got moaked keep
American farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but for a
limited time and now back to me all
right guys let's dive right into it uh
the big story of the week is that Mark
Zuckerberg of facebook slash meta he has
launched threads which is a Twitter
clone this is a direct assault on Elon
Musk apparently there's a whole bunch of
people that are not happy that Elon Musk
has turned Twitter into a free speech
Zone that freaks people out
in comes threads and here's a little uh
video report on that it's the battle of
the billionaires after Elon Musk
recently challenged Mark Zuckerberg to a
potential cage match and Zuckerberg
agreed the two have yet to physically
face off but the source of their dispute
Zuckerberg's company meta is now
entering the ring to take on Twitter I
kind of I enjoy being doubted announcing
the launch of a direct competitor
threads the app which appears to
emphasize public conversations much like
Twitter already showing up in Apple's
app store for users to download on
Thursday photo previews suggest users
will be able to log in using their
Instagram account meta is the biggest
social media company in the world they
can take this to their users their
existing user base and leverage that the
number of users on Instagram worldwide 2
billion compared to some 300 million on
Twitter and Buzz is building on social
media this is what it's going to look
like it's really cool because you can
actually log in with your Instagram
username threads is launching amidst an
earthquake at Twitter since Elon Musk
bought the platform last year he's
changed the verification process
charging eight dollars for blue check
marks overhaul the layout that
determines what tweets users see and
just days ago imposed limits on how many
tweets users can read per day musk for
his part is not modulating his
controversial takes I'll say what I want
to say and if if
if the consequence of that is losing
money so be it
I love how the mainstream media frames
everything somehow Elon Musk because
he's been defending free speech and
making a better product at Twitter which
I think you can truly objectively say
somehow he is framed as the bad guy here
Barnes I want to start with you on this
uh this concept that we somehow need
another Twitter and that people are
knowingly going to a place where they
will be censored I mean really that
seems to be what's going on here Elon
said hey we're going to open this thing
up more conversation is better and then
people are going to the guy Zuckerberg
and the company Facebook meta that has
been doing more censoring than maybe
even Google over the last say three four
years
well I mean I think it reflects two
things one Facebook's badly struggling I
mean Facebook is one of the few big tech
companies out there that's been losing
subscribers and members now uh actually
has net negative growth in many aspects
meta itself didn't really take off in
terms of that whole meta universe and it
almost seems a bit like a desperate move
by Zuckerberg to get back into the game
to get relevant to get pertinent uh as
he sees musk gain in success with the
way he took over Twitter politically
even though financially he's still uh
you know working to turn that around but
uh you're right the other aspect is
clearly his Market Target is the blue
the original blue check mark crowd that
loved the sensor gated controlled
Twitter anyone and they want to recreate
that the question is is there much
popular interest in that and I have
serious doubts about that well it's
interesting because on the numbers side
I just got the numbers while we were
playing the clip they already in in
basically three days of launch uh it's
the fastest growing app ever on the app
store is that what you told me to hit 50
fastest ever to hit 50 million users
they now have 70 million users so
whether we think it's nonsense or not or
useful or not it is taken off here uh
but Viva before we get to the legal part
of it this idea that people sort of want
to be censored I I still can't get over
this concept
Dave I mean if this is the next step in
the full uh flipping of the parties the
liberal left Democrats Once Upon a Time
you know they were pro-choice in terms
of vaccines for the bodies they were
reluctant to trust big Pharma they were
reluctant to trust big big government
and now they are literally you know the
old expression better the devil you know
than the devil you don't they're
literally picking the devil they know
over the devil they know and that's
right I'm inclined to like Elon Musk
more because I think he stands for
principles but they are literally going
to the guy who admitted on Joe Rogan
they met with the CIA they censored the
hunter Biden laptop story and they want
to go there to stick it to Elon Musk
it's it is a full government Me Harder
daddy approach and this is just the
latest iteration of it actually to prove
your point I I had a tweet that went
viral that I think sums it up nicely uh
we'll throw that up I can't imagine the
type of person who not only wants
another Twitter but wants Mark
Zuckerberg to bring it to them uh Barnes
to your point on that original blue
check type of person the sale celebrity
who got the blue check and they like
their gated kind of thing and all that
um it seems like the entire machine he's
got the whole machine going over there
so whether whether we like it or not
again or whether it's needed or not the
machine itself all the good press I mean
I looked yesterday they're getting crazy
good press everywhere while we know
about the press that Elon has gotten
with Twitter uh for the last you know
six eight months
the problem he's probably going to face
is the more success he has the better
the chances of musk's lawsuit against
him succeed because it does look like
they use scrape the same thing that uh
chat DPT is currently facing in the open
AI suit that David and I talked about on
Sunday where they did a lot of web
scraping to build it it looks like
that's what happened in Twitter they use
some web scraping they used some old
Twitter employees who probably brought
some proprietary Intel and information
over to them and I guess Zuckerberg's
willing to take the legal risk it's not
like he hasn't done that in the past uh
in order to build his business or
Enterprise but I think the downside for
him is the greater benefit he gains the
better the Elon musk's suit looks like
and that he musk ends up getting the
ultimate profits even if threads is
successful
so to your point I want to throw up a
tweet from Elon Musk on what's going on
here with some of the potential stealing
of data etc etc Elon wrote competition
is fine cheating is not this is in
regards to former Twitter employees who
may have taken secrets and if they had
signed non-disclosure agreements etc etc
so Viva the the legal battle is going to
fight here but do you agree with Robert
that Zuck might just be willing to take
the hit on that because he believes this
thing's going to blow up either way
um I I am not optimistic for the
successive threads and despite their
initial numbers I mean I think it it's
probably easy to sort of fabricate or
falsify those numbers by promoting
threads to its already existing user
base of two or three billion so those
numbers I think might be wildly inflated
but as a product I want to go over to
threads which is going to be like
Mastodon on steroids so I could see the
Taylor lorenzes of the world and all
these other Legacy blue check marks who
don't think the regular people should
have access to the blue check mark who
complained about everything about free
speech so they can go over to The Silo
good go I won't be joining it I don't
think people who have meaningful
opinions will be joining it it'll turn
into whatever Echo chamber it turns into
but I'm skeptical of those initial
numbers uh and I'm also highly
suspicious of how they actually got
this up so quickly to replicate
Twitter's format it does look like they
were up to some no good chicanery as set
out in that letter of demand which is
now also circulating on the internet and
by the way I saw right before we went
live that apparently if you delete your
threads account it will automatically
delete your Instagram account so that's
one way that they are locking people
into the system but I got one more on
this for you guys just sort of
philosophically to to your point uh Viva
like we already have a political divide
in the country I guess what I'm worried
about here is if threads really takes
off you're going to have a set of people
millions and millions of people who
knowingly are entering a censorious
world who will get that censorious
information whatever that might be and
then you'll have the rest of us right so
the three of us the people that watch
our show and let's say our world is at
least a little less censorious and
hopefully closer to the truth that's not
a political divide anymore that's a
truth divide and I see no way to to
Arbitrage those situations Robert do you
do you think that even matter anymore
like maybe the ship has sailed on that
well I think the people who like threads
are the people who grew up in safe
spaces and want safe spaces to exist on
social media as well they should have
called a safe space right yeah exactly
they've been honest at least honest I
mean threads is your classic Zuckerberg
generic I don't know what that means
language it was like being created meta
it's like what in the world maybe better
uh you know it would have been more
accurate but the we'll see how it all
translates in the end uh I mean I agree
that the other risk he's facing here is
Anti-Trust violations because by tying
in Instagram using his near Monopoly in
that aspect of social media on Instagram
to have to use another product is
exactly what led to all the currently
pending antitrust lawsuits against
Google and and other companies so it
looks to me like what he's doing is he's
not only stole a lot of Ip from Twitter
through him ex-employees and maybe some
data scrape dated Mining and web
scraping but also it looks like he's
violating the antitrust laws and he he's
just like Bill Gates he's the Bill Gates
of big Tech he can't help himself but
engage in illegal activity to get his
profitability right that's exactly what
I was going to say isn't that exactly
what happened to Bill Gates with Windows
you know Circa in 1994 or something like
that uh Viva final thought on just sort
of the divide that we will continue to
go down uh it's not going we're already
there so the fact that they want their
safe spaces it's no different than
blocking on Twitter so they can have
their Echo chamber silos which they do
effectively anyhow but the idea that
they're going to like create something
that's going to beat Twitter
acknowledges Twitter's massive success
in the first place so it doesn't matter
that that uh Zuckerberg has access to
two or three billion people it's the
essence and Zeitgeist of what Twitter is
yeah and I'm telling you it will not
succeed because even if it does it's
going to succeed at being a mastodon
it's going to succeed in a bunch of Hull
monitors uh policing thought shunning
anybody who dares disagree with them and
they'll have their big beautiful Echo
chamber it's not much different than CNN
being broadcast in airports those who
need to know those who want to know and
those who have an open mind will go into
the open area of competitive thought and
those who want to hear Keith Oberman
Rave about how everyone's you know
scared of the facts go to go to Facebook
where you know they're censoring you and
and by the way Zuckerberg had a thread I
guess they're calling it not a tweet a
thread yesterday where he was saying you
know this is going to be the nice place
online and it's like that sounds nice I
suppose but once you say that what you
are saying is we will censor all of the
people who are not considered nice and
by the way nice is going to be even
thinner than the the boxes we're in
right now but let's move to the other
big legal thing of the week because I
know you guys have been hitting this uh
this is about the uh judge who is
stopping the Biden Administration from
censoring us I thought that was pretty
good uh got some info from the daily
wire a federal judge issued an
injunction on Tuesday that bans numerous
top Biden Administration officials and
agencies from communicating and meeting
with social media companies the lawsuit
filed by Missouri and Louisiana accused
the Biden administration of pushing
social social media companies to censor
content related to the coronavirus
pandemic the state said in the lawsuit
that the Biden administration's actions
were the most egregious violations of
the first amendment in the history of
the United States the judge a trump
nominee did allow for some exceptions
for Biden officials to have contact with
social media companies including
informing them of posts involving
criminal activity or criminal
conspiracies National Security threats
extortion or other threats and crimes
related to the U.S elections
um
Barnes this strikes me as extremely good
this is way overdue and I would imagine
that there's got to be a whole bunch of
other lawsuits that people could bring
if their first amendment rights were
were hit by the government during
Coronavirus
uh yes in fact many have brought I have
joined this suit so Missouri and
Louisiana filed the suit initially in
Louisiana Federal District Court Judge
Dodie who's made some really good
rulings in the vaccine mandate contacts
and The Mask mandate context uh one of
Trump's better appointees at the
district court level so he'd probably
already shown promise and here he waits
to publish this to July 4th so credit to
him for that too to have a case that is
truly revolutionary and resounds in the
principles and precepts of America's
Revolution uh because this has been
happening for a while also I'll give a
shout out to Robert Kennedy Jr he along
with the Yale Professor brought this
Theory several years ago before it was
fashionable or a lot of people are
paying attention to it case still
pending somehow before the ninth circuit
they can never get around to ruling on
it but he would challenge Facebook on
the grounds this was collusion they were
acting as an agent of the state now we
now know that all of his allegations
were true and then some I mean they're
still obsessed with Bobby Kennedy in the
white house there's a New York Times hit
peace out on them today
um so the the but this goes to collusion
that there has always been a limitation
on the ability of the state to use the
either the carrot or the stick to get
private Enterprise to do what they want
goes back to a U.S Supreme Court case
called Bantam Books so some people on
the left were saying oh you have to
prove that the state did it directly no
you don't you just have to prove that
the state is without the state it
wouldn't have happened and here there
was tons of evidence that that was the
case this just this is the case where
Anthony fauci had to get deposed so
great ruling by the judge he established
a great evidentiary record which will be
very hard to overturn on appeal by the
Biden Administration and he may came up
with the right remedy he was like you
guys can't be trusted at all so I'm
gonna say you can't communicate period
to social media unless it's within these
constricted circumstances because you've
proven to be unreliable when you're
allowed to do it so it's a it's a great
ruling it's something that we've been
talking about you've been talking about
Dave for many years and it's good good
to see the federal courts finally
enforce our first amendment freedoms
when the the effective digital Public
Square was being manipulated and
controlled for gatekeeping purposes by
our government one of the things that's
so amazing to me about this is how
Brazen the administration was the entire
time they were not hiding it I'm sure
you guys have played the clip and we
plot we probably played it on my show 20
times of Jen saki saying we've as White
House Press Secretary we flag posts for
Facebook so she did an outright thing we
forced them to take it down but as I
always say it's the mafia move we call
them up and we say ah this is an awfully
nice social media company you got here
we wouldn't want anything to happen to
that
Viva so it's like they haven't been
hiding it so I suppose that does help us
in this case right more you know people
see it at least they've been admitting
it from the from the beginning and and
people like well no they're not coercing
they're not you know colluded they say
things like that gentsaki admits it from
the from the podium and it's nothing
more than gangsters a nice shop here
it'd be a shame if something happens to
it first thing first I mean people
should appreciate this is a ruling on a
preliminary injunction so it's not on
the merits it'll be in effect uh until
there's a hear a judgment on the merits
and the people freaking out about it
haven't read the bloody order like the
order all that it says is that you just
posted it by the way yeah I just I just
posted it says all that it says is they
shall not uh let's just say discuss
whatever for the purposes of urging
censorship and they qualify each and
every order with that and then they
carve out if there's a you know security
risk or whatever they can communicate
the whole point is they should never
have been communicating period the wink
wink nudge nudge this is a problematic
account here is not something the
government should ever be discussing
with big Tech or with private companies
we now know from the Twitter files which
everyone seems to have magically
forgotten the election Integrity
partnership or the the EIP
they admitted what was going on they
were doing indirectly what the
government could not do directly this
judge got it on the preliminary basis
we'll see what happens as more evidence
comes out it's not going to make it look
less bad for the government it is what
it is everybody has seen the evidence
who's been paying attention to the
Twitter files and the blue check mark
Legacy Media who want to flee to
Facebook so they don't have to face
reality refuse to even acknowledge the
wording of the order which is quite
rational albeit potentially a little bit
difficult to enforce yes what you just
said there totally links it to the
previous story I don't think these
things are disconnected that this
decision comes down and then within days
threads magically goes up because it's
suddenly like oh if the government can't
do anything Zuckerberg you better do our
dirty work for us and you just won't you
won't talk to the government of course
yeah Zuckerberg wouldn't do that I mean
he only admitted on Rogue basically
censoring the hunter Biden laptop story
don't trust the devil you already know
is the devil people you're crazy Robert
you know one of the things that always
comes up about this is when people go
you know my account was banned because I
said vaccine mandates were coming or I
said vaccines don't work or I questioned
election Integrity or whatever if your
rights are act if your First Amendment
right your ability to speak is actually
infringed on by the government because
they force the social media company to
do something one of the things that I
think people are very confused about is
you really don't have much recourse
right you can maybe get them to write a
letter but they're not going to pay you
out they're not going to do anything and
and I think that that's part it's part
that people don't understand it and it's
part like it just kind of sucks right
yeah exactly and I think there does need
to be more call for federal legislative
change in this Arena Senator Josh Hawley
has done some good work there's
legislation that's on hold in Florida in
Texas that was passed that would provide
some more remedies like in Texas for
example you would get your attorney's
fees if you were wrongfully denied your
access to your account that would
substantially deter them from this kind
of activity uh we need those both of
those cases are sitting about before The
Supreme Court in the next Supreme Court
term as to its constitutionality I think
it's completely constitutional but we'll
see how it works but this decision is
completely as Viva notes on Good Grounds
because the evidence was so overwhelming
that this was not social media doing it
on its own this was them doing it in
collusion with by the coercion of by the
inducement of the government on a
constant continuous basis from some of
the scarier agencies that are out there
I mean as Viva noted that's what
Zuckerberg admitted who was the original
source of suppression of the hunter
Biden laptop Story the Central
Intelligence age
and and by the way as Zuckerberg told
Rogan they didn't even have to say much
to him they basically said a few weeks
before the hunter Biden story this is
basically his words I'm paraphrasing but
pretty much his words were they came
they said something's coming you might
want to keep an eye on it and then he
just went ahead and did all the dirty
work uh I want to show you a clip though
of how the the mainstream media the
corporate press the clown car of
insanity is covering this because
they're not happy that the government's
not going to be able to censor the
average person anymore uh this is a
apparently a legal analyst incredible a
legal analyst named Eli honig on CNN
listen to this yes this is a trump
appointed judge but this judge was
confirmed 98-0 by the Senate just
reading the words in this injunction a
quote massive effort by the defendants
to suppress speech based on content
those are the judge's words calling the
present case quote arguably involves the
most massive attack against free speech
in the United States history Ellie yeah
it's a dramatic decision by this judge
if you read through it he's citing to
literature and George Washington and Ben
Franklin here's what really is
astonishing to me this is a conservative
ideology that clearly comes through in
this decision it's a conservative
political ideology right we saw some of
the quotes questioning vaccines
questioning maths conservative talking
points but the ruling itself is the
opposite of judicial conservatism this
is one of the most aggressive
far-reaching rulings you'll ever see
what this judge is purporting to do is
to micromanage really the day-to-day
interactions between essentially the
entire executive branch all these
agencies that are listed as defendants
and the leading social media companies
and in the actual temporary injunction
the judge basically says you're not
allowed Administration to talk to these
social media companies about any
protected Free Speech except for cyber
security threats National Security
threats criminal threats but where's the
line who's going to police this this is
a judge trying to micromanage the
day-to-day regular activities of the
entire executive branch I don't know
that it's actually policeable
guys I know that they put out pure
drivel on cable news all day long but
almost everything he said there was
completely the reverse of the truth uh
first off he finds it astonishing that
the judge would defend free speech that
seems like sort of odd to me but okay uh
questioning things is somehow a
conservative point of view I mean I
guess that's true these days uh and then
this idea that they're micromanaging
it's the reverse of micromanaging he's
saying don't talk to each other
micromanaging would be exactly what they
were doing Viva say that better than I
said it well I'm going to say one thing
before I forget the thought what he said
at the end was not an opinion it was the
wink wink nudge nudge this is how you
get around the order instead instead of
saying censorship just say hey there's a
national security risk there oh hey look
at that Hunter Biden laptop hat there's
a national security Hunter had some
codes on his computer that was the wink
wink nudge nudge here's the The Playbook
as to how you circumvent this uh court
order just make everything you talk to
them about about national security
online crime whatever what he said
however is the biggest load of partisan
rubbish you can possibly questioning
vaccines and questioning mandates so
it's unquestionable now it's it's of
judicial notice efficacy of the of the
jab and and efficacy of the Mask these
are not conservative talking points what
he said are the liberal Mastodon to be
thread talking points and it's a
wonderful place he doesn't get pushed
back at all and he won't get pushed back
on CNN or elsewhere but it's rubbish but
he was giving advice at the end this is
how the government should go about it
now just claim it's all security Robert
that that concept that viva's talking
about this how do you get around the law
once these judicial decisions come in
it's the second time we saw that this
week because you know after the
affirmative action case the president or
the Inca president-elect of Harvard did
a video we played it on my show where
she basically said they made this
decision and you know you'll have to
write your essays a little bit
differently but we'll figure it out what
do you do in that case if you're a
lawyer or a judge and you know because I
I agree with you Viva they're they're
trying to show people here's how you
circumvent the law what do you do about
that
well there's a major risk because take
the affirmative action example the
Supreme Court specifically said by the
way you cannot use admissions essays as
a way around this right which people
didn't know actually made the University
of California system which has been
using that mechanism to get around its
prohibition on affirmative action
affirmative action is so unpopular it
failed in 2020 in California by 14
points I mean that gives an idea for how
right in Cali in Cali in California
California 40 of black voters opposed it
majority of Mexican-American voters
those the groups are supposedly
benefiting from it many of them voted
opposed to it in fact it was mostly uh
you know upper income West Side L.A
white liberals that were rushing to vote
for it and I think the problem here is
so problem one is the courts have
specifically identified don't do this
like this court has also done and if you
violate it you run the risk of contempt
as an individual so if you're a person
that's doing this you're at risk of
civil or even criminal contempt
proceedings in this judges shown a
willingness to go there so I think that
like so far the bite administration's
internal response has been to say we're
not going to communicate at all at least
that's what HHS and others said until we
get resolution from a higher Court uh on
the issue so they might run the risk of
creating a direct judicial executive
branch confrontation but they definitely
do run that risk look at Harvard after
Harvard got yipping some smart more
blue-collar oriented Democrats of what's
left there in Massachusetts proposed
legislation to tax Harvard's endowment
to help fund apprenticeship programs
training programs and community colleges
and I was like nobody deserves to get
taxed I'm not a big tax fan but nobody
deserves to get taxed more than
Harvard's endowment and they especially
deserve it after they decided they were
going to flout the U.S Supreme Court let
me ask you guys one other thing on this
before we get to the next topic we don't
have to make it about that specific guy
on CNN but when you see lawyers on
television or that you know do the
online thing I'm not a lawyer obviously
but I have a basic understanding of the
First Amendment of the Bill of Rights
the Constitution like when you see guys
that are doing this for a living that
are just so in stark contrast just
directly assaulting the truth it must
make you want to pull your hair out
which for you obviously Viva would be a
real situation it well they're they're
paid influences I mean I don't know if
they get paid directly or not but it's
it's the scratch the bat what does it
patch you on the back scratch each
other's back system it's no different
than like the Harry J sissons or the
krastensteins of Twitter putting out
tweets which if they're not paid
directly there is indirect recognition
remuneration compensation all these
these guys go on they give their 30
second bits to misinform millions and
millions of people there's not even
enough time on that segment uh for
people to truly understand how dumb and
how how factually incorrect what the
person said is but this is how people
get their news this is the biggest
problem and I think it's actually what
has been remedied somewhat with the
longer format content on Rumble locals
Twitter people are realizing the degree
to which they are being lied to by the
so-called expert and they don't trust
anybody as much anymore as they Once
Upon a Time did but people get their
news from this I mean anybody getting
their news from this is going to be
wildly ill-informed
but for you guys running your show on
Rumble which as I said is absolutely
blowing up right now I mean people are
getting more insightful legal analysis
and I I guess Barnes that you're
probably okay with that so you don't
mind when these people go on CNN and
spout this nonsense
well kind of what inspired me I mean I
used to not be a public figure at all I
was just doing my little stick in my
little criminal Tax Defense world and it
was agitation at all the bad legal
advice being given during the Trump era
that led me to become a public figure
because you're right I mean these are
people miseducating the public on a
regular basis about the law can you
imagine saying you know he quoted Ben
Franklin okay
yeah yeah that's how pitiful these
people are yeah and it also reflects
what I call the aristocracy of ancestry
affirmative action combined with legacy
admissions and our colleges and law
schools has not just bred people that
are committed to the woke religion but
has bred some of the most incompetent
professionals we've ever had in the
history of American government state
department CIA the legal profession as a
profession our universities our Academy
they're filled with people who are not
only dangerous in their ideology but
incredibly just flat out stupid and I
often say I don't mind dumb people and I
don't mind criminals but you put them
together and you got a problem oh you've
given me a hell of a segue because I'm
about to show you a clip from MSNBC here
is Andrea Mitchell our final topic they
found some cocaine at the White House
and the Machine is going out of its way
to make sure we will never know who that
cokehead is and turning to some breaking
news we have just learned that a formal
lab has confirmed the suspicion that
that white powdery substance found in
the west wing on Sunday was in fact
positive for cocaine the discovery led
to a brief evacuation of the White House
Sunday night joining us now is NBC White
House correspondent Mike memley so Mike
where do things stand now this is so
unusual you and I have covered the White
House for years I can't even
fathom anything like this having been
found before In The West Wing and I go
back to the 70s at the White House so
this is pretty pretty wild
it's absolutely extraordinary Andrea and
this new conclusive test confirms what
had been the preliminary field test
conducted by D.C fire Personnel who were
called in on Sunday night after the
discovery of this suspicious substance
by a uniformed officer in the Secret
Service that was conducting a routine
patrol of the White House and so to
recap on the developments from that
we've been reporting on yesterday this
was found we understand in a highly
trafficked common area of the West Wing
it's an area where individuals
especially visitors individuals who may
be coming for for instance a private
tour might have been asked to leave some
of their personal belongings before
heading into more sensitive areas of the
West Wing which of course includes the
presidents the vice president's office
some of the most senior officials
offices as well as the Press team and a
number of deputies
foreign
we'll never know who is doing cocaine at
the White House Hunter Biden was just
there uh two or three days before we've
got a little video of Hunter look at
this look at this
oh my goodness
I probably smoked more parmesan cheese
than anyone
the guy's smoking parmesan cheese I mean
guys just like joking aside for a second
the way the media is running around
telling us we are never gonna know
within days somehow January 6th they can
facially ID everybody now they're
telling us that in a highly trafficked
common area in the White House they
found cocaine apparently they found a
bag by the way it wasn't just like
cocaine like on the desk
fingerprints all the people that have to
be id'd to go in Barnes It's just so
bizarre I mean I don't even know what to
say
well I think that was the Babylon B meme
which had uh a picture of uh you know
the bag with it says property of Hunter
Biden on the front and the headline is
we uh they they can't figure out okay so
the I mean that's it it's I mean anybody
who saw the balcony scene anybody that's
been around somebody that's done cocaine
I mean it's obvious that that that's
what honors do I mean he's even
signaling it like he goes to the part of
the that's the video broadcast to the
world and he's like you know I mean he's
telling the world I've always thought
that he secretly wanted to out himself
and his father like it's this desperate
effort I mean who leaves their laptop at
the computer shop right what daughter
leaves their diary that exposes their
father at a local at any sort of drug
rehab facility it's the sign of a couple
of kids desperate for somebody to see
that their father is a is a tyrant and a
in a in a horrible human being that it's
a it's almost like constant cries for
help and here the the great I mean the
other story came out the same weekend
was that Biden had instructed people to
not refer to his seventh Grand daughter
he doesn't have a seventh grade
unbelievable the court says he has a
seventh granddaughter but I mean that's
the kind of insanity that we're at it's
not only the emperor is naked the
emperor is naked and high with a bunch
of coke on his face and pretending the
world is fine so let me do my conspiracy
version of this Viva tell me what you
think of this I think they clearly know
it's hunter or at least at the very
least they know who it is but let's go
on the Assumption for a second it's
Hunter and they want you to know that
they will not release the info meaning
like they want you they want the media
to immediately say we'll never figure it
out because they want you to know they
have Democrat privilege and they can get
away with any effing thing imaginable
Dave it's it's the problem I got a ding
on that one how about that it's the
persuasion just plant that plant to see
that they know is so uh incredible that
no one will believe it but I gotta say
this if you go back and watch that video
look at Jill Biden's face it's almost
like she says darling or honey to Joe
and look over my shoulder something is
going on behind me that shouldn't be she
doesn't look happy and it's wild but
let's let's yeah here we go darling look
over my shoulder look at that tell me
that she didn't just say something
darling and look over what's going on
behind me I know something's going on
that that's my body language reading you
know Robert gets pissed off at bad legal
advice on the internet I get pissed off
at being lied to and being treated like
an idiot and that is exactly what has
been I've discovered has been going on
for a long time they're lying to us
they're treating us like idiots and now
they're telling us we might never know
who the cocaine belonged to it's amazing
what they can't find when they don't
want to look for it they don't know who
scaffolding man is they couldn't find a
crime to charge Ray Epps for they don't
know who The Client List of of uh
Epstein was uh who else could they not
they don't know who blew up the
Nordstrom pipeline but my goodness they
can find a grandma in Alaska when it
comes to tracking down the January
Sixers it's Preposterous they're lying
to you we know they're lying to us they
know we know their lines once it's that
old communist phrase and they do it
anyhow because it's a flex of authority
of the absolute power that they have
they can lie with impunity brazenly and
there's nothing anybody can do about it
except hopefully speak truth to power
which is what we're doing right now yeah
it's that it's that beautiful search and
it's end quote but to your point here's
a tweet from Politico just two days
after the thing White House cocaine
culprit unlikely to to be found law
enforcement official so again they're
just throwing it right in your face oh
and here's what I I retweeted it and I
said and I think I nailed this one it
was Hunter in the library with the crack
pipe so there you go uh Barnes so we
should just wrap this one up right like
we're not going to find out who it was
we'll all just have our theories and
it'll just be another one where they'll
get that pat on the back and
congratulations
uh or maybe uh Jack Smith will bring an
indictment and say it was all Donald
Trump he snuck in he he planted the bag
it was all part of a private tour and
and that will be the next uh indictment
on Donald Trump
yeah I mean Viva you think that like
they would be treating this the same way
if it was Donald Trump Jr let me spit it
the other way it does if they
discovered decipher whose it was then
security at the White House is a joke
they're incompetent buffoons who have no
business running security period they
either know who it is or they can't know
who it is or don't know who it is in
which case they're idiots period by the
way it was the Dobbs leaker they also
don't know who leaked the dogs decision
they can't find these things I wonder
why I know it's that one's just so
incredible that the leaker just was
never found just amazing but watch the
way CNN covered this the way they're
joking about this and again just
contrast that to imagine if Donald Trump
Jr was a crackhead and they found crack
or Coke or whatever at the White House
when Trump was President take a look at
this they're learning that it is indeed
cocaine now again this is part of an
ongoing investigation we're trying to
get more from the Secret Service as
again how this got into the White House
and who brought it in all of those
questions still lingering but at the
very least those lab tests are now in
John an investigation being led by the
Secret Service uh Priscilla and we
should know it I mean clearly they know
everyone who goes into that building it
is a known quantity
that's right I come in and out of this
building on a regular basis and you do
have to pass just like you would at the
airport through
um through security and so the question
now is going to be how this how this
came to be and Secret Service is the one
who's going to be building those
questions
all right it is intriguing Priscilla
Alvarez thank you so much for the latest
on that it was suspected the field test
said cocaine now these more conclusive
lab tests yeah I would like to know Blow
by blow who was responsible for this
too soon
no one was injured as far as We Know
and
it's an illicit drug at the White House
why can't you actually have a bit of fun
with this I don't believe in fun no he
doesn't thank you so much
that is a CNN daytime anchor basically
telling people to do cocaine if you want
to have a little bit of fun I mean the
carrying water here Barn's like oh my
God yeah it's absolutely to another
level and it's because they all know I
mean that the for those that don't know
the only people who don't get searched
in going into the White House or family
so the that's why they know that this
wasn't searched uh Secret Service won't
fall on their sword for this and so the
net effect of it is that everybody knows
it's hunters and of course they know
Hunter's habits and Hunter's history and
there's documentary Visual Evidence
effectively by what we saw there so
everybody knows and the question is do
they all have to hide do they all have
to pretend and it's really it like I
said they keep showing the naked Emperor
over and over and over again and rather
than hiding him behind the curtain
they're just demanding everybody look
and pretend he's not naked
Viva one more conspiracy theory for you
it's actually not Hunter Biden's it's
Joe's and they have him do a little bump
so he appears slightly cogent when they
send him out there what do you think uh
the bottom line is it It ultimately
doesn't matter whose it actually is but
that they say they can't determine it
it's laughable on its face and they're
they're treating people like they're
idiots or that they have so much power
they can lie to them and treat them like
idiots and there's nothing you can do
about it
um but uh we all have our strong
suspicions uh just to compare and
contrast everything everything they have
accused Trump and his family of having
done or doing is exactly what Biden and
his family have in fact done and
continue to do from the quid pro quo
extortion of foreign interests to the
actual PP you know the the strange
hooker stuff I haven't looked at
Hunter's laptop in its entirety I'm
scared to
um everything they've accused Trump and
his family of doing is exactly what
Biden and his family have been doing and
I agree with Barnes these two kids you
know Ashley Biden leaving her diary at a
halfway house Hunter Biden leaving
abandoning his computer at a store it's
a cry for help or they have such deep
hatred for their own father they're
trying to take him down but you know
Biden his uh his Entourage won't let it
happen but that's that's a little
Freudian um Freudian analysis there one
one addendum I don't think zelenski was
probably real happy to have his photo
next to that story given his own
particular interesting habit shall we
say well but yeah exactly zelenski's
doing a lot of this too so it really
does make you wonder hey one thing we
got about a minute left uh I I wanted to
mention you know Barnes and I happen to
be on different sides of the Trump
DeSantis thing at the moment Viva I
think maybe you're somewhere in the
middle but you're also Canadian by birth
so you can't vote in this thing as
American as you are and Floridian by
heart uh but I I said to Robert right
before we started that like you know so
much of it has become so vitriolic and
the fact that Robert and I can agree to
disagree on some of this is maybe
something that could be modeled and at
the end of the day I certainly will vote
for Trump if he's the nominee and I
don't want to put words in your mouth
Robert but I assume you would vote for
DeSantis over Biden if he was the
nominee and maybe that's what we need a
little more of these days yeah I think I
think both campaigns would be best well
served but Trump's going to be Trump
that's his Trump Style but focus on
positive policy proposals that either
one can Embrace down the road get some
more same with Robert Kennedy I want to
see more policy proposals from RFK give
us some details give us some meat that
we can use no matter that go beyond the
individuality of the personality of the
candidate that can last past the next
four years put some real legislative
policy proposals out there so that they
can rally the populist base and rally
conservatives and rally Libertarians and
rally Independents independent of which
personality they like get some good
policies we can all unite behind
well said Viva I don't know that
anyone's ever given a Canadian the last
word but I'm going to offer it to you
all that I can say is I'm glad I'm not a
fence sitter on the DeSantis Trump I'm
indifferent because whichever one wins
uh they're both good I'd rather have
DeSantis in Florida because I've
invested the next couple of years of my
life there I personally don't really
think DeSantis could put up with the law
fair the full weight of the deep State
against them the way Trump is doing I'm
not sure anybody on Earth could put up
with what's going on other than Trump I
I don't think I would be able to so it's
a win-win for me in a sense
um but the fighting has been very
vitriolic and I think as far as the
influencers or as far as the social
media types go I don't think the
rhetoric's going to get toned down I'm
just excited for the primaries to be
over so the real political battle can
begin
on that note I want to send everybody
over to Viva Barnes uh it's
viverbornslaw.locals.com correct correct
indeed okay got it got it and uh you
guys are blowing up on Rumble and
everywhere else it was an absolute
pleasure my friends have a great weekend
and I'm going to continue on for all of
our local subscribers at
reubenreport.locals.com in about 30
seconds I'm just going to do a quick
line and then I'll see everybody on the
other side okay ciao
and by the way you know I should
understand and it get hot I got a lot of
I got hairy legs that turned that that